[Music]
the program monday edition pro football
talk live nbc sports radio nbcsn hello
to our friends in the uk enjoying the
program on sky sports usa peter king
kind enough to give us an hour of his
time his new football morning in america
column chock full of all of the combine
nuggets that you'll need to know plus
plenty more available now at
nbcsports.com and profotballtalk.com
peter joins us this morning peter how
are you buddy
hey good morning mike everything's going
good it's good to get that extra hour of
sleep not for you but did you
no no no but i also uh you needed to
sleep because you actually worked last
night you had to file your column i just
watched the oscars although i didn't
really watch the oscars my wife and i
have figured out the perfect hack for
watching the oscars you watch like the
first 20 minutes then you like go do
something else for two hours and then
you reconvene and just fast forward
through all the awards nobody cares
about it was perfect we ended up
investing
less than half of the total three hours
in watching the oscars
it's you know what is madness about the
oscars i found over the years you're
absolutely right they do one right at
the beginning
and then there's nothingness for a good
90 minutes
and you're right you not only should do
something else you should empty out your
dvd player or look at your dvrs of all
the things you have recorded and watch
something else for an hour and a half or
watch jeopardy or something you know the
tournament tournament of champions which
is now big in our house but
it's i think it's borderline unwatchable
from 8 30 to 10 15.
yeah it really is they milk that thing
for three and a half hours every year
and people watch it although i have a
new way of watching it i'm ashamed it's
taking me this long to figure it out but
that's going to be the new procedure
going forward all right we got plenty to
get to throughout the course of the
final hour we have a draft coming up of
the best players about whom a biopic
could be made that is in honor of the
oscars but uh an item that came up on
friday there's no good transition away
from what we've been talking about but
big cat who was with us on friday he
texted me in the middle of the afternoon
after everything kind of hit the fan
with robert kraft saying thank god this
didn't happen while we were on the air
because i can't imagine trying to
process all this i couldn't process it
and we weren't on the air it i i saw it
peter and i was like what is this is
this a joke is this is this so i i
didn't get it and it took a while for it
to all sink in but robert kraft charged
with two counts of solicitation of
prostitution along with 24 25 others for
now more names are expected to emerge in
the coming days and weeks and then you
peel the onion a little bit more and you
realize that on the back end of this at
the at the massage parlors in the strip
malls where this kind of thing was going
on you you had
quite possibly human trafficking going
on very disturbing very sordid story
your first reaction when you became
aware of what was happening on friday
you're right mike i i'm glad i didn't
have to make sense of it 10 minutes
after it came out because it would have
been very hard to do so
uh there the element of human
trafficking really complicates matters
as does
the nfl's recent history over the last
five years it was five years ago this
month that the ray rice story exploded
and i think it creates a very difficult
problem
not necessarily for roger goodell but
probably more for robert craft in that
if he is found complicit if he's found
guilty
i think it's going to be a very
difficult case
for him to basically go and uh plead for
lenience
for this reason
you know five years ago the nfl gave a
very upstanding member at that point
a guy who was a very upstanding member
of the player society in ray rice you
know he was the guy who the ravens
relied on to
you know
appear in public to be their spokesman
for an anti-bullying campaign in
maryland uh and and everybody you know
in the media knew him as a go-to guy in
that locker room he's very well liked
and so roger goodell gave him a break he
gave him only two games then the video
comes out there's the controversy over
that
and all of a sudden the nfl is light on
crime against women they're light on uh
you know the respect of women after the
video is shown
that uh you know that he punched his
then fiance
so
insert roger goodell in the middle of
all this and look at what's happened
over the years you know with josh brown
the giants kicker and with with a few
other things and you get to what ken
belson of the new york times wrote on
saturday in his analysis of this case
which i thought was absolutely spot on
basically saying that you know despite
the nfl's attempts
to uh you know be responsive to women's
concerns over the years they are seen as
basically being tone deaf as at women's
issues
and so that's why this thing becomes
significantly more important the element
of human trafficking now which is just
surfacing is a huge
uh sort of kind of
me too movement in our society you know
a wake up movement kind of in our
society add that to it and i think if
craft
uh is found to uh have used these
services a couple of times and there is
video i think it's gonna be extremely
hard for him not to face a significant
suspension
a spokesperson issued a statement on
friday on behalf of mr kraft we
categorically deny that he engaged in
any illegal activity because it is a
judicial matter we will not be
commenting further and the legal process
will play out the nfl has its own
process and one of the things that the
nfl decided to do peter in the aftermath
of ray rice no longer defer to or
necessarily even wait for the criminal
justice system the nfl has its own
in-house justice system which really
isn't about justice see this is what
happens when the nfl decides to police
the private lives of players as a matter
of pr this isn't about creating a system
where there is fair and appropriate
punishment that is meted out to players
based upon the things they do off the
field this is about pr and when you
create this machinery to enhance your
league's pr
sometimes people that you didn't think
were going to find themselves in the
gears of that machine are going to be in
the gears of that machine and that's
what the commissioner is going to have
to deal with as it relates to robert
kraft how far do you go
how
how
big of a suspension gets imposed how
much of a fine gets imposed i know there
are limitations in the constitution and
bylaws but ultimately everyone's going
to be watching the commissioner here as
to how he handles this and he's probably
going to get criticized no matter what
he does and maybe that will be the best
decision if he's equally criticized by
those who say he went too far and those
who say he didn't go far enough but i
guarantee you peter no matter the
outcome there will be people on both
sides saying it's too much and saying
it's not enough
well anybody who lives in new england
i'm sure is going to say it's too much
uh no matter what it is uh you know the
vast majority of patriots fans
you know i think are going to say that
but
look roger goodell has a uh has a
responsibility
as long as there is going to be a
personal conduct policy mike
and you know as i wrote this morning
when the you know when washington is on
fire
and the nbc nightly news
you know with 8 million viewers
leads the newscast
with
this sordid story about one of the most
respected owners in recent nfl history
uh and the uh
you know the backbone
of a of an organization that has had the
longest running single era dynasty in
nfl history
when when he is uh uh
at least at this point
accused
of the acts he's accused of
uh there's no way that the nfl can say
that well we're not going to
hand down if
again if it's true and we just learned
in this ge in this jesse small it case
in chicago that we have to let
you know the events in this play out
we haven't seen this video uh and we
don't know everything about this case
that we need to know yet but if it is
true i think it's it's incumbent as long
as there is a personal conduct policy
that by the way
holds owners and league employees to
quote a higher standard end quote
that kraft would face a significant
sanction for this
yeah and even if he is suspended it's
not going to affect the football
operation he's not like jerry jones
where he's made himself the gm of the
team he lets bill belichick handle
things and you know peter from the
football side of this and we're
ultimately a football show not a not a
you know a real-life crime show but uh
to turn it to football
it will have no football impact on the
patriots they are the one team in the
nfl that is best suited to just move
forward and not pay attention to
whatever it is that happens and if
there's a suspension that's imposed so
be it the team will move forward and
they won't think twice about it and
they'll focus on football other teams
may allow it to be a distraction other
teams may get consumed by it but the
patriots the one team that will figure
out
exactly how to move forward and pursue
championship number seven in no better
or worse position today than they were
before the news came out on friday
i i mean you're absolutely right mike if
you look back at
all of the cases uh and obviously
through all of their controversies they
haven't won the super bowl that year but
you know look the year that tom brady
got suspended for four games he comes
back and leads the greatest comeback in
super bowl history uh the year that
spygate breaks you know the patriots
have the perfect regular season
so i i just i i don't see any
impact on the day-to-day operation of
the patriots other than
the meetings that bill belichick for
let's say and i'll throw a number out
there for four or six weeks
let's say the meetings that bill
belichick
would have had with robert kraft he'll
have with his son jonathan craft who
clearly is being positioned to take over
this team in full one day so i i don't
think in a football sense it's gonna
mean anything at all
and you know the one incident that came
up during a season the deflategate
controversy that was right after the fc
championship game four years ago and
they went on to win that super bowl they
they shrugged that thing off and they
focused and they got that game won so uh
i do think that the patriots from a
football standpoint that's what their
fans care about from a football
standpoint i think the patriots will be
no different than they would have been
before this all came
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports